hi there's a Cesar Millan and you are in
white 100 episode party so come with me
stay calm submissive and enjoy the party
episode celebration like grill like that
to me I was like I have to be there
because I was just a video of this video
yesterday I was like you know I have got
to give back for my boy to celebrate
this right here like you were saying
before this is a monster
a milestone
the work that he does is just amazing to
be able to hear and celebrate that it's
truly an honor Oh
and gets done you know I help but with
dog she helped me with life so we're
good team
I brought spike
14 this year found this little fellow
down the block probably belong to
somebody
this is my dog Lila a miniature
schnauzer she's about 8 years old
we're big fans
as you can see we have pretty mellow -
love Caesar I love the show big
supporter and you know I love my dog so
that all goes hand in hand does it he's
a big Laker fan so
mutual admiration
for male Rottweilers that you can walk
without a leash I mean every kind of
blows your chest up so I mean I really
learned
kind of find that inner power what in
full control full command you know and
so I learned how to take that and put it
into my life
so good to see everybody here to
celebrate the hundredth episode of the
doll
thank you sir birthday party
happy 100th Mike is an old man now he's
like I should be home by now what are
you doing still out and now we exercise
where's my brandy I hope you enjoy this
party keep your dream big and your face
stronger